pero ha amanecido en medio de la
incertidumbre los ciudadanos hasta ahora
no entienden como el país salió de un
mal gobierno para entrar a un
desgobierno sin jefe jefatura en el
parlamento y sin presidente que gobierna
esta nación los ciudadanos van a tener
mucha expectativa a la jornada que se va
a realizar el día de hoy el congreso ha
citado a las dos de la tarde para una
nueva sesión de balotaje de la que se
espera salga el nuevo presidente de este
país y asimismo las nuevas autoridades
que van a regir el poder legislativo
para ponerle más suspenso a la cosa el
tribunal constitucional señaló que hoy
también me iba a revisar la demanda
competencial interpuesta por el
presidente martín vizcarra para algunos
juristas y otros especialistas en la
materia si es que el tribunal
constitucional emite una sentencia a
favor del exmandatario martín vizcarra
en la cual
podría señalar que el congreso sobrepasó
sus facultades de relación con el
ejecutivo las cosas podrían retornar a
martín vizcarra nuevamente al poder y
terminarán las marchas luego de esa
nominación que nos identifica es
francisco de las nuevas autoridades del
parlamento y del gobierno
ayer estuvimos hasta la última hora de
la jornada y pudimos ver alegría en los
ciudadanos porque pudieron conseguir
sacarle del poder a manuel merino a
quien no aceptaban como presidente pero
también había mucho enojo porque es el
descontento de la población estaba en
que los congresistas no pudieron elegir
a las nuevas autoridades y ellos nos
dijeron que van a continuar las marchas
porque la situación no era solamente
sacar a merino sino defender en la
democracia por la que ellos están
luchando y señalaron que no confían en
el parlamento y van a estar muy atentos
a las elecciones que al candidato de la
mesa directiva que va a ser nominado
como mandatario en este país